she's an American technology executive
activist and author she's the chief
operating officer of Facebook her
estimated net worth is reported to be
over 1 billion dollars
she's sheryl sandberg and here her top
10 rules for success and so I thought
about you know what I wanted to say what
would I pass on if you are trying to be
an entrepreneur if you're trying to be a
leader and I think if you're trying to
be those things what you're really
trying to do at a fundamental level is
have impact you're trying to have impact
you're trying to have the things you do
the things that you spend your time
doing have impact meaning change
something around the world and for me I
think the lesson is really simple and
it's particularly important in the era
in which we live and for me the industry
in which I work which is that this is
all about scale it's all about scale
having impact is all about how you do
something that scales and by scale I
mean things that can have broad impact
potentially things that have decreasing
marginal cost things that can scale
beyond the one to one interaction you
have as a person I think the most
important thing about growing a business
successfully is thinking ahead about
where you're going to be so I think
about like the three tips you have for
scaling an organization the first I
think the most important is to think big
people think about how do you manage how
do you motivate an organization and I
think about management you know
basically the science of administering a
business or leadership and my favorite
definition of leadership is the art of
accomplishing more than the science of
management says as possible when you
have a big vision when you're thinking
really big something that can change the
world so my favorite example connecting
the world which was Mark Zuckerberg was
vision for Facebook that's the kind of
thing that excites people and motivates
them that gets them to follow you not
just because they work for you and they
need to do what you say well because
they believe in what you're trying to do
and when you're trying to really scale
an organization you need to go really
quickly and get people to accomplish
more than they thought was possible and
I think that comes from internal
motivation which really comes from a
vision that's big enough I think the
most common mistake I see people make
and men make this mistake too but women
do do a lot is they're too worried about
the upward trajectory and not worried
enough of that growth so the two
corporate jobs I've taken I went from
Treasury to Google and I went from
Google to Facebook had one thing in
common which is that they were more
junior other people's words not mine
than other jobs I was offered when I
went to Google Google was like 250
people I was going to be a business unit
general manager except there were no
business units Susan Wojcicki is he or
she helped recruit me this was a non job
of all time I mean there was no job
there and I was offered like senior
sounding see more senior roles at more
established companies but I really
believed in what Google was doing and
Eric Schmidt gave me great career advice
he said go for growth growth moves
everyone up it's growing it works and so
I went to a smaller company with a very
more junior less defined job you know
when I came out of Google it seems
obvious now to come to Facebook but at
the time a lot of people asked me right
you remember this what are you doing
you're going to work for a 23 year old
you know no one knows that Facebook's
gonna be the next you know MySpace or
Friendster like and you're not CEO you
could be CEO somewhere else and what I
saw was something that mattered Facebook
matter the top 10 tech identity and an
opportunity for growth and so at each
stage I've cared less about my level I
kind of think it's silly then I have
about the underlying growth and I do
think this is really important for
everyone to know how do you communicate
authentically how do you figure out what
to say and what not to say in a way
that's authentic and what Fred says and
I really believe this is true is it
starts from the fundamental
understanding that there is no truth
there's my truth there's your truth and
everything is subjective and so if you
always start from the position of this
is what I believe I don't expect you to
believe it I don't think you have to
believe it I'm not saying it's true
you can actually always communicate
authentically because if you walk in the
room and this gets worse as you get more
senior here
the answer you're not giving anyone else
any room to say anything and if you walk
in the room and say I believe this
for this reason what do you believe if
you share your truth in that language
you give people room to authenticate to
communicate authentically and that is
hugely important to these relationships
at any stage I think the second thing is
you have to hire big and big I don't
mean famous
I mean ahead of where you are so when
you're growing an organization really
quickly what happens is that what
normally takes an organization years
happens in a period of just months so
when I was at Google you know my team
went from four to four thousand in about
five years that means that if you look
at those first four people I hire in
order for them to be part of the people
who are running that organization they
need to do about you know 10 or 15 years
worth of growing and you know getting
experience in a much shorter period of
time so if you think you're going to
grow quickly hire for what you think
you're going to need over hire hire
people who are more qualified have more
experience or hire people who are right
out of school but can over achieve in
their current roles I don't think it's
that number of years in the workforce
that matters I think it's hiring the
people that you're going to need then
now because then happen so quickly I
really believe we lead best when we walk
side by side with our colleagues and to
achieve this you're going to have to do
the opposite of what I'm doing right now
you're going to have to not just talk
but really listen and you have to go one
step further which is not just listen
but find a way to get people to actually
tell you the truth there is no such
thing as complete control nothing
no one has complete control in any
situation people that leading
organizations in some ways have less
because not only do they have to control
what they do they have to help persuade
everyone else what they do but you know
if you are able to take responsibility
I'm not late because there was traffic
I'm late because I didn't leave early
enough to the
for the fact that there was traffic the
project didn't get finished not because
my friend my partner didn't do it my
colleague didn't do his part the thought
the project didn't get finished because
I didn't set up a team where my
colleague wanted to do his part when you
take responsibility and you take full
responsibility that is the most
empowering thing and you can do it at
any stage you have to do it if you're
raising money as an entrepreneur you
have to do it if you are if you're
trying to persuade people to work with
you you have to do it at all stages one
of the things I talk about in my book is
the importance of measuring results not
face time if you as a company measure
face time you will be rewarded with face
time if you talk about the people who
are working really hard rather than the
people who are getting great results
people will work really hard but not
focus on results in my job at face book
mark and I try to run the company very
focused on results we had one employee
actually for a while who famously was
one of our absolutely highest performers
but Justin liked to be in the office
very much at all
and we would publicly applaud him you
know no one's seen shamov in a week but
look what's happening and we were
publicly saying his results were amazing
if he feels like doing it you know
sitting in his basement go ahead now not
every company can do that different
companies have different constraints but
many more companies can do this the best
kind of leadership starts by finding
something you really believe in Facebook
exists because Mark Zuckerberg believed
that the world would be a better place
if we all use technology to share and
connect he believed in that enough to
drop out of school at 19 and he believed
in it enough to hang on to that vision
and hold on to it
even when people tried to take it away
from him over the years I joined
Facebook along with so many others
because I too believed in that vision
and now it's the most important part of
my job to keep myself and everyone else
at Facebook
I hope we focused on what we are trying
to do day in and day out so start start
by finding a company you believe in a
product you love something a cause you
really really care about because not
just not only will you inspire yourself
will you be inspired but you in turn
will inspire others and that's the most
critical part of great leadership all
organizations have some form of
hierarchy people in organizations if
you're their manager will do what you
tell them to do even at Facebook at
least some of the time but great leaders
don't want compliance they don't want
people to follow orders great leaders
want real excitement genuine enthusiasm
real commitment great leaders don't just
win the minds of their team they win
their hearts great leaders don't just
issue commands to heed the voices of
those around them careers are not
ladders those days are long gone but
jungle gyms don't just move up and down
don't just look up look backwards
sideways around corners your career and
your life will have starts and stops and
zigs and DAGs don't stress out about the
white space the path you can't draw
because therein lies both the surprises
and the opportunities thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Veronica Watts asked me to so if there's
a famous entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Cheryl's
top 10 rules meant the most to you leave
it in the comments I'm going to join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching you need to believe and I'll
see you soon she's an American
technology executive actor
no not actor activist not an actor she's
not an actor she's an American
technology